i want to hear the secrets that only the
employees know okay
i worked at mcdonald's and i learned so
much
so much mcdonald's you think that
they're just fast food and [ __ ] but they
have so much science behind everything
so for example your straw mcdonald's is
larger do you know why it's larger
because it lets more carbonation hit
your tongue and makes the soda taste
better that's why it's better at
mcdonald's that's why 7-eleven little
straws suck their grilled chicken is
injected with a salt water mixture to
keep it moist
but also flavorful mcdonald's actually
commissions coke for their own recipe of
syrup that's why their coke has a little
bit more sugar and a lot more flavor
their ice cream machine is made from
whole whipping cream and it's cleaned
once a week did you know that tyson
actually makes the chicken nuggets
they're actually not that processed and
they're made by tyson and they're
privately labeled
all right so i worked at best buy for
the better part of a decade ironically
wearing a blue and yellow hat
not on purpose so the big one is you
don't have to buy that protection plan
if you go back in the store and your
product isn't working within a year they
can actually take it back right then and
there give you a gift card for credit
and if they tell you they can't honor a
manufacturer warranty they're full of
[ __ ] ask for a manager if you're gonna
buy a cell phone from them just know
that it's more expensive to buy it from
best buy than it is in a carrier store
the carrier store is going to be about
150 bucks off
if you're ever gonna buy an open box tv
or a big ticket item try to get it on a
saturday night because they need to hit
their numbers for the week and they'll
be more willing to work with you to get
a deal done
if they try to sell you an hdmi cable
just say no you can get the exact same
thing on amazon for like four bucks
the last thing is they actually lose
money on computer sales so when they try
to give you a bundle deal with whatever
accessories they have you're actually
not getting that great of a deal
i used to be a cashier at marshalls and
i always thought this was the weirdest
thing um one time i was working you know
on register and some woman comes up to
me and she's like hey i just saw this
girl steal a whole bunch of makeup put
it in her bag
she's over there and i literally had to
be like thank you but we cannot do
anything about it and she looked at me
like
and um
take like home goods you know marshalls
tj maxx see our trading post if you go
to any of those tjx companies we
literally legally cannot go up to
someone and like accuse them or even
keep a record of them stealing let me
explain by their logic we could be
putting the whole rest of the store in
danger if we go up and confront them
granted we could still go up and be like
did you find everything all right but
that's about oh
that's about it i worked at hollister
and i think it's different now but back
in the day it was kind of messed up
there were two positions one was called
back stock and one was called model and
the model was like the customer service
people who actually were on the floor
and dealt with customers in order to be
a model you had to be attractive and in
the interview process they rate you from
a scale of one to ten you had to keep
your hair and makeup natural you
couldn't paint your nails and you could
only wear their clothes that were navy
blue and white including shoes so when i
worked there they only had the flimsy
little flip-flops and i just had to wear
those on my shifts and the reason
they're called models is because
apparently hollister like all of their
ad models all of the models in the
pictures were pulled from the employees
and on black friday they always picked
the skinniest girl and paid her more
than everyone else to stand in the front
with the shirtless guys it was so messed
up it was always just on looks
you